thank you for clicking on my face you
know i love you for that glad i haven't
bored you yet and before we get started
as usual i do want to thank the sponsor
of this video this video is brought to
you by the sony bravia xr a80k 4k hdr
oled tv because in this modern day and
age of more and more film premiering on
streaming services they all got to upper
tv game if tvs are going to take the
place of movie theater screens for some
film the cognitive processor xr
understands how humans see the real
world deliver intense contrast with deep
blacks high peak brightness and natural
colors it understands how humans see the
real world if the robots are listening
we do appreciate everything you do for
our lives to make our lives easier
just so it's out there in reality if you
haven't rocked an oled tv yet the only
danger of it is once you do you will not
go back to anything other than oled so
click the link below to up your tv game
bring your living room into the world of
the theatrical experience and there it
is a sponsorship so epic it changed my
shirt but now we talk about the premiere
pilot episode whatever you want to call
it for house of the dragon so house of
the dragon is a prequel series that
takes place about 200 years before the
events of game of thrones based on the
george rr martin book fire and blood i
think it's called i should check yep
fire and blood
the cover of the book says it takes
place 300 years before so [ __ ] if i know
and of the shows coming out around this
time house of the dragon was tops for me
that and the better call saul the final
season of better call saul better call
saul finale which i do still want to get
you a video on i'll try to do it this
week all depends on how this week looks
for me life [ __ ] i won't bore you with
it if not this week next week but
eventually i do want to give you a video
on better call saul because that is just
great character drama it looks like we
might get great character drama with
house of the dragons looking forward to
it because let's face it anything that
can wash the taste out of our mouths
from the finale you know
ellie i'm down for that because in game
of thrones was at its top at its peak it
was an incredible show and there is a
correlation between game of thrones
being great and they had george rr
martin's works to go off of and game of
thrones slipping and falling and they
didn't anymore and this being based off
of a george rr martin book is like okay
i'm down for this and house of the
dragon sets up a world that looks like
it's aiming to give you to give us what
i personally liked most about game of
thrones which was
wait for it
a game of thrones when people were
plotting scheming backstabbing playing
the game of thrones all for a chance to
sit on this horrid smelted piece of
sword seat that was what i loved about
game of thrones the walking north never
really cared i wanted to care i really
tried to carry tried my best but never
really cared about the zombies as much
as the political scheming there are some
cool things that happened with that
whole situation absolutely
but i never cared about it as much as
when the characters in the show were
playing the namesake the game of thrones
and this looks to bring that political
scheming but all in one family within
the targaryens and other people are
going to choose sides between the
targaryens it's going to be daemon
targaryen and um rinera the names are
still new it'll it'll take me a second
i've already seen people say oh this is
a slow burn it's not as exciting or
action-packed as game of thrones i'm
like pretty sure this pilot episode had
more action than the pilot episode of
game of thrones i mean granted jousting
yeah but still more action we're all
gonna miss characters like tyrion
lannister absolutely there's no tyrion
lannister style character that was like
oh that's the guy immediately but it has
a great assortment of characters that
looks to give promise to this world
that's going to boil simmer and spill
over into war civil war that's a lot of
the tension in westeros westeros is a
largely patriarchal society it's like a
woman cannot take the throne
just kind of weird how cersei was like
i'll do it
okay i did it i mean granted she had a
big zombie monster with her but you know
i feel like there should have been more
adam smith as damon targaryen was
incredible i haven't read the books i
don't know if he's book accurate but i
thought he was great in this show
in this episode of a show and when i
heard matt smith was cast in this show
that has to do with targaryens i was
like oh yeah
that tracks there is no man alive
there's more targaryen looking than matt
smith he's that side of the coin you
know the phrase every time a targaryen's
boring the gods flip a coin which if i
really think about it we've only ever
really seen
the bad side of the coin we've seen
those targaryens looks like rhaegar
targaryen was pretty decent but history
is written by the victors so they were
like no he's a total [ __ ] because we
say so but all the rest viserys you hear
about the mad king daenerys was like you
know what i will barbecue people most of
the targaryens have been [ __ ] to the
point where you start doubting the
phrase because you're like is it really
a coin flip is it 50 50 or is it 80 20.
feels more like loaded dice than a coin
to me but in the show you see decent
targaryen folk i guess i should rephrase
decent decent
for westeros and the thing i was
concerned about it was considered like
okay we're gonna revisit westeros but
it's you know 2022 it's now will social
media tolerate the brutality the
zeitgeist of westeros i don't know it's
yet to be seen but i was impressed with
the facts like oh yeah this is a raw
horrid horrific world still and that's
what it's supposed to be you know we're
not supposed to look at westeros and be
like we should be more like that i was
impressed that they kept the familiar
brutality of westeros and didn't wrap it
in bubble wrap so to speak love the
music too i love the fact that you hear
some game of thrones mixed in there but
largely a lot of targaryen music i
thought the targaryen theme or the song
that became i don't know if it was
supposed to be the targaryen theme but
it largely became the targaryen theme in
game of thrones you hear that theme in
here and i just
it feels game of thrones but also feels
new and it feels most importantly very
targaryan there was some lore expansion
too that i really like when he was
talking about aegon targaryen's dream
that he called the song of ice and fire
can't help but chuckle at the fact that
in canon aegon targaryen had a dream a
vision of when the show game of thrones
would die iron throne got a facelift wow
that's a lot more swords which yeah if
you see the throne from the original
game of thrones series you see the
conceptual throne that george rr martin
intended like that's
yup those are different you could tell
they were like we want to be more in
line with what george rr martin
envisioned but we can't just make an
entirely different throne it would feel
different you know it would feel like a
different world a different universe and
it's supposed to feel like it works in
tandem with game of thrones it does feel
like all right we had the decoration we
had the throne and they were like need
something else kind of like you're
setting up christmas decorations or
something you're like you need something
else i put a little holly on the sides
yeah that's good it does look more
menacing though say that
that's a man that is a conqueror's
throne that's a targaryen throne right
there you know my big take away the
yellow dragon was named cyrax if i was
hearing it correctly i believe it
sounded like the yellow dragon's name
was cyrax tell me the red dragon's name
is sector yellow cyrax that can't be a
coincidence george rr martin plays
mortal kombat confirmed i mean why
wouldn't he dude murders characters and
novels for a living why would he not
murder video game characters in mortal
kombat it just only makes sense so house
of the dragon was great setup great
intrigue it's a prequel series in the
world of westeros which judging by the
premiere looks to bring the world of
westeros back to what i liked about game
of thrones and let's face it it's a
family that i've always felt in the
world of game of thrones they're always
the most interesting family at least
had the most interesting history all
right so the premiere of house of the
dragons on hbo have you seen it what did
you think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]
you